[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans dimanche en
politique il ya une semaine emmanuel
macron été réélu président de la
république dans les semaines qui
viennent le paysage pour les cinq
prochaines années va se mettre en place
les élections législatives à commencer
par ça c'est dans 42 jours et elles
seront cruciales notre invité
aujourd'hui et françois bayrou président
du modem l'un des piliers de la majorité
sortante et haut commissaire au plan en
attendant le prochain gouvernement
bonjour françois bayrou et maire de pau
et maire de pau absolument on est
aujourd'hui le 1er mai fête du travail
les syndicats organisent des
rassemblements partout en france avec en
ligne de mire bien sûr la retraite à 65
ans étaient dans le programme d'
emmanuel macron emmanuel macron doit-il
tenir bon coûte que coûte sur cette
réforme de retraite à 65 ans
est ce qu'il existe une autre
possibilité
que de faire une réforme on dit faire
une réforme en réalité retrouver
l'équilibré des régimes de retraite que
les français soit assurée sur le long
terme pour toute la durée
des décennies qui viennent que ceux qui
sont retraités toucheront des pensions à
la hauteur de ce qu'on leur a promis et
que ceux qui travaillent ne seront pas
surcharger de cotisation comme on dit
c'est à dire qu'on leur prélèvera pas
leur salaire parce que comme vous savez
c'est les prélèvements sur les salaires
des salles à des actifs qui fait le
financement de la retraite des pensions
que les vins mâcon doit tenir mais tout
le monde doit tenir il n'existe pas une
retraite pour les ans une retraite pour
les autres
tout le monde voit bien que ce système
là est un système pour l'instant
déséquilibré on a besoin de revenir à
l'équilibré et d'ailleurs c'est très
simple le gouvernement socialiste d'il y
a 6 ans
avait mis en place une réforme la
réforme touraine qui est une réforme en
deux par cette réalisation qui portait
allongement de 1 trimestre tous les
trois ans de la durée de cotisation et
qui portait cette durée de cotisation
autrement dit l'âge de départ à la
retraite à
64 ou 65 en et c'est donc la même chose
sur un rythme un peu différent
vous posez la même chose que la réforme
de françois hollande en fait c'est ben
c'est la même nécessité qui s'est imposé
à tous les gouvernements successifs
fillon autrefois et puis hollande et
puis maintenant et sans fourrure et sont
précises pour de nom pour une raison
extrêmement précises ont dit on va faire
quarante trois années c'est ça la
réforme touraine de durée de cotisation
or vous savez très bien à quel âge les
français arrivent au travail en moyenne
10 arrivent au travail 23 ans et en
région parisienne ne 24 heures pour pour
simplifier 23 ans + 43 ans ça fait
combien savent 66 chez spectra de
quelques hauts que je pensais aussi à ma
prochaine question parce que pendant la
campagne emmanuel macron n'avait pas
exclu la possibilité de passer par un
référendum sur la question est des
retraites ce serait une bonne idée j'y
suis favorable depuis je crois l'avoir
proposé à l'élection présidentielle de
2007 donc vous dites qu'ils ont à
référendum ce serait une bonne je vais
vous dire le en quelques phrases le
raisonnement qu'est ce qui fait que
cette réforme des retraites est
totalement explosive je crois que michel
rocard avait dit c'est une réforme qui
fera sauter plusieurs gouvernements
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une espèce de
blocage du le pays chaque fois que
j'aborde cette question et si ce blocage
est une réelle menace si peut-être on
trouvera une autre manière de faire je
le souhaite mais si ce blocage est une
menace réelle alors ya un moyen très
simple pour lever le blocage c'est de
dire ce sont les français qui choisiront
donc le référendum est donc j'ai
toujours défendu cette idée du
référendum je dis pas que c'est une idée
majoritaire elle ne l'est pas mais alors
qu'elle est vrai qu'elle est toujours
pertinente vous voyez bien ce dont il
s'agit
si comme on l'a dit en commençant cette
émission c'est une réforme non pas pour
un gouvernement mais pour les français
parce que c'est les français qui sont à
la retraite et qui paye et c'est pour
eux que la réforme est faite et qui paye
et c'est pour eux que la réforme le fait
eh bien il est légitime si on est en
situation de blocage de leur remettre le
choix et moi je ne doute pas que ce
choix ira dans le sens de l'équipe
retour maintenant une semaine en arrière
vous étiez au pied de la tour eiffel
dimanche soir dernier pour écouter
premier discours d' emmanuel macron
réélu avec le regard déjà tourné vers
demain
une victoire à 58% mais pas vraiment un
air de fête le mot d'ordre était
sobriété
l'histoire on retiendra de ce soir là
qu'il est le premier président réélu
hors cohabitation mais que 42 % des
votants choisis l'extrême droite c'est
conscience que ce vote mobilisent pour
les années à venir proclamée en lui
bien sûr de la satisfaction en même
temps de la gravité le sens de ces
millions de français et de ses millions
de français qui ne l'ont pas recoudre
apaisé aller au contact dès le lendemain
le président semble comme en campagne
la punition emmanuel macron aime
surprendre convoqué jeudi les ministres
pensez déjà leur dernière séance arriver
mais le président prend son temps pour
choisir son prochain premier ministre
je voudrais quelqu'un qui a été attachée
à la question sociale et la question
environnementale à la question
productive alors une femme un homme une
écolo va-t-il consulter ses proches pour
trouver l'oiseau rare le président
macron avait dit je veux un premier
ministre modèle en quatre j'ai lu cette
déclaration le fait que je sois berné
comme henri iv et que j'ai écrit sur lui
plusieurs livres
ça ne fait qu'ajouter au sourire au delà
de penser qu emmanuel macron d'un
président libre des tests se laisser
enfermer même par ses amis libre comme
les français d'ailleurs d'interpeller
désormais un président qu'ils
connaissent bien tout le monde
les petits chèques c'est bien dans la
vie de vrais salaires il ya une grande
différence aujourd'hui entre les bas
salaires et ceux qui sans congo quand
vous aurez je vais traiter ce problème
là je pense que vous aurez vous pourrez
voir la vie en france beaucoup plus
facilement
françois bayrou vous entendez les
français qui demandent des augmentations
de salaires va-t-il falloir à un moment
que les employeurs fasse un effort sur
les salaires
alors il ya plusieurs négociations qui
sont en cours et même plusieurs qui ont
réussi qui on te abouti tout le monde
voit bien la question on est devant une
vague d'inflation mondiale provoquée en
grande partie par la guerre en ukraine
et en partie par la crise des matières
premières qui lui est profondément lié
est-ce qu'il faut augmenter les salaires
il faut augmenter les salaires en
liaison avec les entreprises et c'est le
seul moyen pour que ça réussisse et
c'est à dire je vous rappelle que vous
voulez revenir un peu en arrière en 68
il ya eu une augmentation massive des
salaires 80 ce qui s'est passé aussitôt
d'évaluation association d'évaluation
inflation dévaluations successives
c'est à dire que c'était ce qu'on
appelle de la monnaie de singe de la
fausse monnaie
ce qu'il faut c'est un pays suffisamment
productif je vous avais entendu le
président de la république qui dit
social écologique c'est normal productif
productivité
travail sur la question de la production
que la france redevienne parce qu'on est
là s'il ya des décennies qu'on a perdu
tout ça un pays qui produit si on
produire nous avoir augmenté les
salaires sinon je crois que c'est de la
fausse monnaie il faut produire plus
pour augmenter les salaires il faut que
tout le pays se met en production c'est
d'ailleurs à peu près la même chose pour
les retraites si vous y réfléchissez si
nous allons vers le plein emploi il ya
plus de questions de retraite si nous
allons vers le plein emploi ya plus de
questions de finances publiques ou en
tout cas elles étaient elles sont
extrêmement réduites tout se tient dans
un pays tout se tient son activité son
son allant et son moral et la question
est au moins autant moral que de
l'activité alors vous avez entendu vous
l'avez souligné d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron veut accélérer la planification
écologique avec un futur premier
ministre qui aura ça dans sa feuille de
route quand j'entends planification je
rappelle que vous êtes haut commissaire
au plan ça pourrait être vous finalement
voyez non mais ça pourrait on va on va
s'arrêter à la première phrase que vous
avez dit oui la deuxième j'étais
beaucoup
revenons à cette question il ya trois
ans
ou deux en
planification ça faisait rire tout le
monde y compris votre métier ça faisait
même peur a personnellement ça
organisait ses soviétique ça faisait
anachronique ça faisait même peur et est
donc je je me suis battu puisque avec
quelques autres pour dire mais vous vous
trompez on ne peut pas gouverner à court
terme donc quand le présentateur de
gouverner allons devoir personnel de
votre part ouais je n'interprète pas ça
soit ça c'est comme ça que j'interprète
ça se souvient j'interprète passa sous
cet angle pour moi
retrouvez la conscience que le travail
politique doit se projeter à 10 20 ou 30
ans et pas à 10 20 ou 30 jours et
parfois à 10 20 ou 30 heures parce que
c'est ça qu'on fait aujourd'hui pour moi
c'est absolument sans qu'un à la fois
pour l'écologie
si je prends les questions écologiques
la question de l'énergie vous êtes
écologistes vous même je sais pas si je
peux dire c'est que si on cherchait dans
ma généalogie on verrait que je suis né
dedans c'est que mes premiers pas
politiques ont été dans ces milieux là
avec des gens comme josé bové par
exemple je parle de plusieurs décennies
en arrière quand nous avions 20 ans
c'est de là que je viens mais
pour moi l'écologie j'enfonce une porte
ouverte c'est une dimension désormais
donnent à leurs hommes politiques de
chaque mais la question est ce qui se
pose c'est selon vous pour mener à bien
ce chantier qui sera donnée aux futurs
ou à la future première ministre quel
doit être le profil de ce premier
ministre techniques ou politiques
politique
ce alors il ya des techniciens qui
peuvent être politique mais c'est pas si
vous si vous mesurez la situation du
pays c'est pas si les commentaires le
milieu des commentaires et des
commentateurs quand il parle de qui va
être à matignon on a l'impression que
c'est une course de petits chevaux comme
paul et que je voulais dire je reviens à
la question il n'est pas possible de
assumer la tâche que la constitution
fixe c'est à dire
fixer la politique du gouvernement est
dirigé la politique du gouvernement
il n'est pas possible de le faire si on
ne s'appréhende pas dans son ensemble
les difficultés de la société et ça
c'est éminemment politique et ça c'est
la politique c'est à dire on ne prend
pas l'action publique dossier par
dossier avec la vérité dans le dossier
et des chiffres dont on croit qu'il
résume tout on ne peut pas prendre la
responsabilité de cette action si on ne
mesure pas en même temps ce qu'est la
crise morale que le pays traverse à ce
propos ce qu'est le sentiment de
frustration d'une grande partie du pays
on parlait des bas salaires par exemple
et pas seulement d'une grande partie du
pays qui ne s'estiment pas reconnu
françois bayrou n'est pas normal ni
acceptable pour un démocrate comme je
suis comme beaucoup d'entre nous sommes
que les extrêmes face dans notre pays on
va y aurait de 50 ans va y revenir mais
vous avez vu passer comme moi le nom de
véronique b d'agde ex-directrice de
cabinet de manuel valls numéro deux du
groupe immobilier nexity qui a été
approché reçus à l'elysée pour être
éventuellement première ministre est ce
que ce genre de profil ne correspond pas
du tout donc je ne connais pas ceux des
non mais vous dites ses doigts de
politique mais pas celle d'orange part
du profit comprenez moi
essayons de ne pas simplifier
la compétence technique
les chiffres les statistiques tout ça
compte et c'est pour moi un sport que
j'aime beaucoup mais ça suffit pas
j'aime beaucoup les chiffres mais ça
n'est pas ça la question la question
c'est le pays dans ses profondeurs si on
ne comprend pas que on est devant une
espèce de tremblement de terre qui dure
depuis plusieurs décennies et ce
tremblement de terre fait que ceux qui
forment la base de la société ceux qui
sont au travail ce qui sont à la
retraite ce qui cherchent du travail
ceux qui sont en formation se sentent
coupés du sommet du pays et faire la
politique doit rétablir sa ou du
prétendu sommet et la politique de la
rigueur tandis que c'est un sommet
mon âge si j'ose dire et il doit
rétablir sa mais le travail de la
politique ses dessous d un pays le le
but de la loi les technocrates qui font
c'est l'unité d'un pays de l'est
technocrates peut-être d'ailleurs y at
il des gens que d'appel technocrates qui
ne sont pas on dirait que on disait que
le président de la république était de
cette catégorie les pages garantissent
et il a une approche politique du sujet
on a besoin d'avoir
un 1er mai ce politique la capacité de
souder un pays comprenait de ressouder
un pays je sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte que la future assemblée nationale
va être juste et moi on va en parler 12
et 19 juin les élections légistatives
l'heure des grandes manoeuvres et
recommencer personne ne veut laisser sa
place à gauche comme dans la majorité
un troisième tour pour le troisième
homme de la présidentielle
en vous appelant à mes lire comme
premier ministre je vous appelle en
vérité à faire vivre un nouvel avenir en
commun pour notre peuple jean luc
mélenchon déjà premier ministre les
affiches sont prêtes mais l'union de la
gauche reste un chantier les communistes
à rentrer au bercail les écologistes
veulent y croire la maison socialiste
tremble et nous avons toujours cette
ambition de réussir ensemble à faire
gagner au moins 289 députés de gauche
insoumis socialistes communistes
écologistes
aujourd'hui j'estime que l'accord est en
vue nous pouvons nous pouvons être
d'accord sur l'essentiel et même bien au
delà il n'y a aucun sacrifice chacun à
respecter pleinement dans son identité
et d'ailleurs c'est bien pour ça que je
vous dis que c'était une rencontre très
positive jeu ce que cet accord ne sera
pas acceptée s'il est signé enfin s'il
est bonne le parti social aura décidé de
disparaître avec 13 millions de voix
marine le pen continue à imprimer sa
marque et ignorent la main tendue d'eric
zemmour pour une alliance dès le premier
tour équation plus difficile chez les
républicains comment sauver les meubles
les sièges le parti ça fait cinq ans que
je m'oppose à emmanuel macron hewitt 5
ans je le dis embrassons nous folleville
parce que je préfère des initiatives moi
je veux que les partis de gouvernement
travaille ensemble il faut dire que la
majorité présidentielle a de l'appétit
droite gauche sont les bienvenus le
centre déjà là mais au siège du modem le
patron veille jalousement sur les
circonscriptions on mettrait très
moderne dans beaucoup de ces
conscription le train de modène partout
où on considérera qu'ils sont les
meilleurs vous êtes 57 madame et
apparentés aujourd'hui c'est bien déjà
si ceux qui ont bien travaillé et
peuvent être élus
et puis si on peut en avoir quelques-uns
pour faire émerger une nouvelle
génération ce sera bien 577 députés pour
quelle majorité écrasante ou serré pour
le président ou pourquoi pas une
cohabitation
françois bayrou le modem il ya aussi la
république en marche évidemment agir et
puis dernier arrivé d'edouard philippe
qui s'appelle horizons qui ont vocation
à être la majorité de demain on va
s'arrêter deux minutes sur ces enjeux là
souhaitez-vous vous pour les
législatives des candidats avec une
seule et même bannière par exemple
majorité présidentielle où chacun sur
son étiquette une seule étiquette il
s'appellerait on verra se trouvera mais
une seule étiquette moi moi je pense que
il y à des sensibilités différentes
dans la majorité et je trouve nécessaire
que l'unité soit affirmée et donc sont
les actions que ce soit clair pour que y
ait pas ces guerres de clans qu'on a
connu beaucoup trop longtemps le parti
socialiste en a et l'udf dans le passé
tellement souffert l'udf c'était un tout
petit peu différent parce qu'on est en
compétition avec le rpr de huy ha vu
cette époque il ya eu des donc eu unité
est pour moi le deuxième mot clé c'est
pluralisme chacun a sa sensibilité
ce sont des sensibilités très proches
mais s'il y aura des places pour tous
très proches environs les proches
d'edouard philippe pour les gens du
voyage de en tout cas je pense
nécessaire connaît un climat de travail
en commun et de respect mutuel dans une
femme manière et un seul groupe à
l'assemblée l'homme annonce oui ceci est
une autre question là vous avez un nom
j'observe depuis que je suis en
politique que lé groupe pléthorique
explose toujours
c'est que chacun garde à ses futurs
auxquels je pense qu'il faut un nombre
limité
d'expression à l'assemblée nationale
mais qu'il faut cependant dû plus râler
je vais vous dire en particulier
pourquoi parce que ça va paraître
bizarre l'assemblée nationale un
règlement intérieur qui donne plus de
poids aux groupes d'opposition qu'au
groupe majoritaire si vous avez un
groupe majoritaire émettons six groupes
d'opposition comme en toul annonce est
bien la majorité aura un septième ou
huitième seulement du temps de parole
vous voyez ce que ça veut dire en gros
vous avez l'air enel les questions du
mercredi 1 trop s'unir par voie c'est
l'un des avantages quoi c'est pas
seulement sur ce règlement j'entends ça
n'ait pas la souplesse que le pays
requiert on a besoin d'unité
mais pas d'uniformité légaré le pays et
divers vous avez entendu le dimanche
soir que dimanche et dirigent ou que
vous citiez le président de la
république a dit je veux tenir compte de
toutes les sensibilités du pays et bien
cette nécessaire reconnaissance
de ce que la france est diverse de ce
qu'il y a des histoires diverses et des
parcours divers mais elles peuvent
travailler ensemble je j'appartiens à
une famille qu'on appelle
démocrate-chrétienne des spiritualistes
on va venir et européennes et puis il ya
des gens qui viennent de familles
sociaux démocrates peuvent travaillent
ensemble ils ont fait l'europe ensemble
et donc ces familles là moi je souhaite
que l soit à la fois unie et reconnu
voilà unis aux élections mais chacun
reconnu pour ses spécificités à
l'assemblée nationale carte blanche à
sophie de ravinel journaliste politique
au figaro
on se fie bonjour francis bonjour france
avez-vous suivi la gauche au figaro et
de ce côté là vous êtes servis il ya du
travail et alors justement vous parliez
tout à l'heure d'unités et pendant que
ça s'organise vous mettez en ordre de
marche dans la majorité il ya un accord
à 4 qui est en train de se dessiner à
gauche est ce que c'est pour vous un
danger
ce n'est pas un danger c'est
quelque chose qui trahit l'histoire et
l'inspiration du parti socialiste en
particulier n'est ce pas le cet accord à
4 dont vous parlez qui n'est pas ça le
fait derrière le programme de la france
insoumise de jean luc mélenchon qui a
dit clairement que c'était derrière lui
derrière son programme est derrière son
épique est et ce programme c'est quoi
c'est sortie de l'union européenne de
fait
c'est le sortie de l'otan il a reporté
tout ça oui
non vous n'êtes pas défenseur de jean
luc mélenchon je parle des sur jamal
déception je parle des faits gelée le
soir la question dans les buzz il a fait
toute sa campagne en disant voilà il
faut sortir de l'otan de l'organisation
de défense des graines ils vont sortir
il faut trouver d'autres alliés il avait
même évoqué qu'elle
des alliances avec des pays sud
américain
et puis il dit il faut désobéir aux
traités européens
ça c'est un projet mais si on me dit que
c'est le projet que le parti socialiste
a porté de 2 87 adhérents quand même
c'est non ce n'est pas un don inné
croyez pas d'ajustement c'est tellement
incohérent que je ne je n'imagine pas
une seconde que des français pour est
désavoué leur choix de l'élection
présidentielle en se livrant à ceux qui
la deuxième question désordre on a
entendu jean luc mélenchon à sa
stratégie de troisième tour de dire eh
bien écoutez vous n'avez pas pu faire de
moi le chef de l'état fait de moi le
chef du gouvernement qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette stratégie est ce que
justement elle est réaliste vous avez
enfin qu'il a rendue c'est une blague
c'est une blague mobilisatrice à plus
mais c'est une blague vous n'allez pas
me dire que les écologistes vont choisir
la voie que je viens de décrire ou que
les socialistes vont choisir la voie que
je viens de décrire le il se trouve que
je connais beaucoup de responsables de
gauche alors dites moi et vous il
voulait dans l'oreille qui ne sont pas
d'accord passeron l'oreille tout face à
face ou téléphone qui vous dit qu'ils
s'arrangent si si si si moi c'est ma ds
je ne travaille jamais les conversations
donc c'est simple des responsables de
partis des responsables politiques de
partis vous avez entendu françois
hollande oui mais c'est pas ça c'est
justement celui là oui alors jusqu'à 9
stéphane le foll enfin jeu oui mais cela
on connaît alors opposition mais olivier
faure au ps comme julien bayou ont une
majorité a priori dans leur parti pour
tenter de faire un accord non mais si si
vous pensez que les grandes sensibilités
politiques du pays se réduisent à une
décision d'appareils les français
voudraient sûrement rhizome les hauts de
seine et val dans les sondages entend
bien que vous défendez cette option mais
une défense et moi il y avait un mental
je voulais déjà 17 qui est sorti il ya
48 heures disons que à gauche les
français étaient majoritairement
favorables moi je n'ai aucun avis sur la
question mais permettez moi de vous dire
que ceci serait une telle injure à
l'histoire aux convictions aux valeurs
de au moins deux de ces courants
politiques là que ça ne vous semble pas
réaliste mais ce n'est pas réaliste
c'est une offense l'habitat est une
cohabitation c'est hors de question mais
une collection de vins toujours arriver
mais qu'on prétende faire une majorité
cohérente à partir de courants
politiques qui sont opposés sur tous les
sujets sans exception sommes vraiment
c'est quelque chose qui me paraît une
offense à la démocratie telles sont les
arrimer telle qu'on la veut on entend
richard ferrand qui est donc le
président de l'assemblée nationale a
fait appel dans le midi libre a lancé
disons un appel aux hommes et aux femmes
de gauche le site donc les sociaux
démocrates dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure mais aussi des socialistes des
écologistes à rejoindre la majorité
est-ce que je vous le suivez est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec vous tout à
l'heure francis letellier parlait de
bernard cazenave est ce qu'il pourrait y
avoir des personnalités de ce type là
que vous verriez entrée avec faveur dans
le gouvernement en tout cas bernard
cazeneuve que vous venez de citer il ne
peut pas accepter la stratégie est ce
que vous souhaitez rien leur exemple est
très longues nuits travaillées lui la
majorité sera large entre des courants
qui se respecte et qui s'estime j'ai été
opposé au parti socialiste une lente en
grande partie de ma vie je j'ai mené des
combats nous avons mené des combats les
uns contre les autres logos et mes
concitoyens savent ce dont je parle
locaux et nationaux mais cependant nous
ne sommes pas étrangers les uns aux
autres tant qu'ils seraient les avenues
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous au fond
pour que on est une économie de marché
plus efficaces et mieux partagée nous
sommes tous d'accord pour que l'écologie
soit le cadre de notre action et nous
sommes tous d'accord pour que l'europe
soit considérée comme bien notre
attention est pas comme notre difficulté
à partir de lampe peut construire
bienvenue à eux
et tout majorité doit avoir vocation à
s'élargir alors justement à propos de ça
à droite aussi la recomposition
s'annonce il nicolas sarkozy que vous
connaissez bien se propose de faire le
pont entre la droite et la macro nier ce
que vous le soutenez dans cette démarche
donc je trouve que tous ceux qui veulent
qu'on construise des ponts plutôt que
des murs mais celui là précisément dans
la bonne direction
moi je me suis nous avons eu des
oppositions nicolas sarkozy et moi
quelques-unes et par un vent violent
dans l'histoire mais cependant quand on
se voit on se parle et c'est l'art de la
réconciliation
j'ai comme vous le rappeler gentiment
vie avec le sourire beaucoup écrit sur
henri iv oui et le livre que j'ai publié
sur henri iv qui a été qui a été
remarqué à cette époque là et encore
maintenant ce livre là il est dédié il
ya une dédicace
et la dédicace dit ceci ce livre est
dédié aux amoureux de la réconciliation
c'est un livre qui a 30 ans et ça reste
votre line motive et ça reste une
nécessité vitale la france est un pays
dont la vocation est d'être unis l'unité
d'un pays depuis l'ancien régime ne pas
seulement depuis aujourd'hui et cette
unité là on a le devoir de la cultiver
autrement la phrase la france est
malheureuse et elle explose elle explose
trop aujourd'hui on a besoin de la
réunir
l'assemblée sauf merci merci merci
sofinex comme tous les 1er mai depuis
1988 les dirigeants du rassemblement
national ex front national sont allés
déposer une gerbe au pied de la statue
de jeanne d'arc à paris ces jeunes note
bardella qu'il a fait ce matin
le rn espère avoir au moins quinze élus
pour faire un groupe à l'assemblée
nationale c'est la dose aujourd'hui
souhaitez vous qu'il y ait un front
républicain pour empêcher qu'il y quinze
élus ou au contraire qu'il faut que le
rn est un groupe dont ils en auront plus
si vous regardez les chiffres c'est je
le regrettais où c'est normal c'est
normal je suis partisan de la
proportionnelle ce bruit toujours je me
suis battu et on va y arriver
je suis absolument certain que les mois
qui viennent vont faire constater à tout
le monde à toutes les forces du pays que
on a besoin de reconnaître les
différents alors ça oui mais il faut
convaincre emmanuel macron qui l'a pas
fait au premier quinquennat mais est-ce
que alors justement est-ce que vous êtes
engagés à le faire pour le second
quinquennat oui il l'a dit publiquement
et de manière mais cette fois ce sera la
bonne notamment à pau je le crois mais
ça n'est pas seulement la décision du
président de la république c'est
l'exigence profonde qui vient de cet
éclatement des forces qu'on a sous les
yeux vous voyez bien tout ce qui se
passait et vous croyez qu'on peut
continuer à dire à tous les citoyens
désormais mesdames et messieurs il va
falloir que vous obéissent y est il ya
une force politique il y aura une force
politique qui sera dominante est votre
rôle à vous sera d'obéir c'est fini tout
ça le passage en force pour moi c'est
fini le moment est venu que avant chaque
grande décision on réussisse à faire
partager par le plancher en bois aussi
les jeunes créent et vous détruit sa
qu'il y à un front républicain
circonscription par séquences si on y
aura front républicain et on sait pas
comment il est fait le ce qui est ce qui
est proche doit se rassembler mais le
rapport de force désormais c'est que je
crois les deux candidats qui ont été
deuxièmes et troisièmes les courants qui
ont été deuxièmes et troisièmes à
l'élection présidentielle loin devant
les autres c'est courant là vont
nécessairement être représentés à
l'assemblée nationale en avait
j'aimerais qu'il le fût ce de manière
organique organique que ce soit normal
qu'ils éprouvent à rien il ya des filles
que ça soit la loi et que les voix de
tous les français soient égales vous
venez pour un courant politique vous
serez représenté à la hauteur du
nombreux que vous êtes merci françois
bayrou d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans dimanche en bétique réalisé par
tristan dans la rédaction en chef pierre
sébastien tout de suite sophie le saint
pour l'activité de la mi journée